comment vous dormez vous avez un lit ou
bien vous dormez en apesanteur et b et
non en impesanteur on a un sac de
couchage qui est accroché au mur on
flotte et tu t'endors un peu en flottant
avec les gens qui flottent les bras qui
flottent et la première fois c'est un
peu bizarre parce que quand tu te
réveilles le premier matin tu as tes
bras ils vont ils se mettre en position
un peu comme ça de repos c'est la
position naturelle des articulations et
quand tu te réveilles tu as des mains en
face de toi tu dis waouh qu'est ce qui
se passe est en fait c'était c'était
propre mais voilà après tu t'habitues au
début ça fait un peu bizarre